[Music]
hey screen junkies we'll be back from
holiday break next week but until then
enjoy this Mega mix of every parody song
we've ever
made that's
Miserables meet the spirit of human
Redemption John valon AER old Thief now
on the run another assumed identity for
reasons never made clear in the entire
movie who must face off against
inspector ja an officer with such
terrible priorities put the entire city
of Paris on lockdown to stop a man who
already served his time follow along in
their epic game of cat and mouse that
spans 20 years which is almost as long
as the movie
feels meet Fantine a random factory
worker who brings an incriminating
letter to work for no reason and is
fired sinking into desperation so deep
she becomes the most pathetic woman in
France in just two verses of
song watch her with no hair watch her
with no teeth yet she becomes the most
desirable prostitute in town which
she'll blame on H Jackman even though he
had nothing to do with
it it's and half away like you've never
seen her literally she drops dead after
only like 20 minutes of screen time
leaving beljon to now care for Co said
her precocious child who was scared in
the dark but totally cool letting some
stranger drag her around the
city now at the dawn of Revolution one
young man will give up everything for a
woman he's met through a
fence pring a heartbreaking romance we
know nothing about because the entire
subplot is glossed over to make room for
countless scenes of
Borat not since the Dark Knight Rises as
a movie been so many live with its use
of time jumps and not since Chicago has
a movie tried so hard to convince you
that movie musicals are a good
idea featuring awardwinning songs but
they all sound the same so without the
track listing you won't be able to tell
one song from
another experience over 2 and 1/2 hours
of CGI cran
shot and extreme
closeups the death of Russell Crow's
acting
ability
starring I have a very annoying
for I really really really wanted to win
an
Oscar I should have never agreed to sing
an entire
movie there really should have shown
less of me and more of
appenine Beetle Juice Beetle Juice
Beetle Juice
if your girlfriend doesn't appreciate
you after sitting through this movie
then you should really rethink your
[Music]
relation Frozen the exposition song do
you want some
Exposition some information through a
song the song that sounds like it's from
Wicked For The First Time in Forever
Disney Let Us
Sing For The First Time in
Forever it's as good as Lion
King the Romantic duet we are about to
P totally going to
P the other romantic duet I'm kind of
turned on by reindeer
[Music]
the anthropomorphic Sidekicks comic
relief song when you're out of ideas you
give them a singing
Snowman the one you skip we are cutting
eyes cuz we are
cutting the one you don't know the words
[Music]
do and the YOLO song Get It Out get it
out
get get it out get it out I'll sing
anything else
instead The Lion King the be careful
what you wish for song oh I just can't
wait till that
dies the plotting evil stuff song so
prepare because I am the bad guy be
prepared for me to do bad guy
things the catchy song to distract kids
from the horrific death they just saw I
went through
tra at a very young age don't be down
kid they just killed my
dad forget all that an African catch
friend the slow jam we are going
are yeah we are totally going
[Music]
to
childhood but now it's time to
p and the song that fools us into
thinking these animals live in
harmony don't know what words
will no one knows what we are saying but
it's fun to sing it anywhere no one
knows
all he could eat
us
is
to remind us we
PR The Little Mermaid the dumb mermaid
song I'm a dumb
mermaid don't know what this or that is
either the obligatory villain song these
boring bad guy songs so blend so blend
but to move the plot along the villain
has to have a song but in the soundtrack
it gets ski the shouldn't you ask for
consent for her song sing with me
[Music]
Nowak to match find out andk the
girl the traumatize your kid song
Killing
fish killing fish yes we show children
this even though the heroes are all fish
like if they made Sushi of Nemo and Dory
you'd have something as messed up as
these and the one we're about to get
stuck in your head e so
catchy e so
catchy there's no escaping these songs
are amazing and
so you'll never get it out your head
you'll see to words you are dead even
when you sleep it plays on repeat it's
so
catchy so what the message it's kind of
sexist girls don't need brain cells just
seashells also don't be F but you ignore
that CU it's
[Music]
[Applause]
sketchy The Lego Movie everything's
a this is allloy so kids more and more
pricey plastic product
at your mom's Lego
Store 3 2 1 have you seen this F of
course you saw it this what buil the
tripping our profit with the number one
toy got people going into the Lego many
ouru we don't own Batman not our product
Lego B that's our product Batman movie
product everything's a
product we're licensed intellectual
property shiny yellow
products now give us your money
g a no Dumbledore the d k you know
what's part of everything TR Track Shack
they product cars bars guitars they
product board sword double they product
all the things you see in this are
products watch him
grow from cute kid to win
emo he just kind of walks around and
never really does anything
[Music]
else and There She
Goes dating string of drunk a
holes could have saved a lot of
trouble by choosing her ex he wasn't
that bad
[Music]
Cinderella the song that inspires false
hope this s is about
[Music]
deception most dreams just don't come
true but I am the rare
exception I'm skinny and pretty and cute
the cute little mice song We Are People
we can kill you go ahead
andbody no one will believe you watch
just handle the scissors we tear apart
your inard stab your eyes out with a
needle watch us get medieval don't mess
with my two people and the Oscar
nominated gibberish song blurp blurp A
derpity derp a bity blabby blunk
anything Rhymes if you you make up the
words slippity zappity flippity flappity
these writers clearly were
drunk 50 Shades of Gray not starring
these horrible lines from the book that
thankfully didn't make it into the movie
his voice is warm and husky like dark
melted chocolate fudge caramel or
something I feel the color in my cheeks
Rising again I must be the color of the
Communist
Manifesto his erection Springs free holy
cow written
La Bas
La holy crap he's wearing a white
shirt I flush at the waywardness of my
subconscious she's doing her happy dance
in a bright red hula skirt wish would
tase me right now the St sex as right
now and this line that
[Music]
did I'm 50 to up H what does
that even mean Toy
Story the song from po
story it's a story about some toys that
come to life for a little boy blah blah
blah blah blah y toys it's the song from
Toy
Story you're watching Toy
[Music]
Story and that's a wrap man this job is
easy hey everybody who wants to meltdown
some gold records and Grammys and go for
tacos my treat I still love La
Aladdin the narra song a framing
device for
whimsic the credits will go much faster
you know so the young kids won't
fail the telling kids it's okay to steal
song stealing it's fine if you need it
get yours forget the police feed me or I
will disturb the peace where did you get
a French IET that's how cartoon bread
straw the take your kid to the bathroom
song time to pee nothing to see your
AA wash your hands zip up your pants you
can trust
me Aladdin's turn to a prince don't
worry it'll make sense no need to whine
anymore your kid
can the kidnapping your dates on I just
kidnapped this
girl cuz her mid driff is
sexy we are up here now let's see if
she'll rub my lamp tonight I'll pork
this
girl as long as that's okay with you no
creepy longf dudes or family feuds to
keep us both from porking you'll pork
this
girl sentient rug can watch us too even
though you're a fraud I like that so
I'll enjoy an Airborne pork with you you
are so much hotter
[Applause]
than and the Robin Williams
song
do Jack Black do that Jim carrot pull
this off without his m
M your Jackman son is sa
aony the torch can pass go head recast
but I'll always be the best always be
the best give the Remake talk rest it'll
be a mess cuz I'll always be the best
[Music]
gen you ain't never going to recast
me the Jungle Book the is this even a
song song's no to
singz barely is a song it's a monotone
it's a boring
drone that there's no need to prolong so
let get this boring song the time
killing gibberish
songish I got to kill some scream is
minut
long
up as long as it rhes the touchy Uncle
song I'm a
creep don't trust
me like a
van with free
C the week and pork when we're Elder
song
[Music]
You Lead You
On I'll flirt with you from a
distance till the day that we can
por and the only song that you actually
remember look you're a homeless Refugee
R diapered homeless Refugee if you don't
starve you'll get eaten
alive yes you're a
liability who almost ends up killing me
in real life I would eat you too so
by The Nightmare Before Christmas the is
this a Halloween or Christmas movie song
what's this what's this is this a
Christmas flick what's this then why the
spooky stick what's this like grins or
die hard it's kind of both things hey
just pick one and commit what's
this is it Christmas or is it Halloween
it's mixed take one look at this scene
you see the streets are lined with toys
and happy children but I look like I
might kill them how can so Divergent
coexist screw this and The Perennial
classic the we keep Hot Topic in
business song boys and girls
ofe you
like and
[Music]
lick this is
Mak
[Music]
take a
yourh I am the oneing in a nerd crap
Harlequin legging spider stat I am the
one selling Deadpool hes anime shirts
and
[Music]
do Rudolph the Red-Nosed
Reindeer you know Dasher and Dancer
and
[Music]
[Applause]
and
[Music]
who wait this prepubescent
reindeer had a neon whistling
nose and when someone else sees it their
tiny little mind
explodes all of the other the
reindeer treat him like he's got the
plague no do of mine is going to be seen
with a a Rednosed Reindeer they into
Exile the sand is full of
rage you should be ashamed of yourself
then one of Santa's slaves his gring
J he'll be a dentist someday which is
clearly code for gay
come here open your mouth out
[Music]
the who who helps them fight a
ye while he odly licks his
[Music]
tools okay okay hold on I got to stop
you right there this is nuts none of
this is from the Christmas carol it's
just ins filler you all turned a simple
story into like Lord of the Rings for
kids on acid don't do it don't you dare
start singing
[Music]
it so s can't
see they use Rudolph for his light and
pretend their friends tonight the moral
of the
story is that being different bad unless
your defect's
useful man this movie's really sad sorry
to Willie Wonka and the Chocolate
Factory featuring the creepy man song
seems like a nice
guy giving treats to
you never ask for money just a creepy
hug with to creepy man the creepy man
can go his got a wi van with even more
candy
the dear God please help a
song they are slaves in need of
rescue
Lo their legs are weird cuz he broke
their KN Wonka showed up and he fed us
some sweets then we woke up in this
giant Factory we get talk back without
getting a smack in the first draft we
all were
don't believe
Google and that this place is a lawsuit
waiting to happen
song you'll fall in burn your skin in a
world of safety
violations my factory has no Health
regulations we don't really Brew can be
right we just TOS some choos to
it every surface someone chewed it our
chocolate river is mixed with
seage Shrek that Smashmouth song that's
been stuck in your head since 2001 back
in the late 9 when Matrix jokes were
timely couldn't get away from these C
because Smashmouth made a tun Love by
children and buffoons and it hit number
four on the
Billboards well the place start coming
and they don't stop coming stuck in your
head for like 20 years running it's more
films and just this one Rat Race mystery
man Digimon this song is lame this song
is DB but sh Made It Go triple platinum
and here's something you can't un see
the SAR is Guy F SM Rich did the sound
tack got p b up at your hand every time
it gets play if you think they're
un go support them at your
county the they really into Coconut song
you can't escape we're going to keep you
around and force you to stay exactly
where you are but hey we coconut hell
yes coconut sweet we're all obsessed
with the coconut it's
so you're marry a coconut when you turn
13 we
that you all are praks the uhoh we're
making the rock sing song you can smell
what I'm cooking I'll save your
franchise make money no problem you all
recognize my voice my B but in one
respect I'm kind of
flawed I can do anything except sing
autotune couldn't get me on track I'll
be president someday still I can't sing
but who else pulls off a fatty pack the
Let It Go is song
After
Disney to sing a
clone of Let It
Go if a song about girls feel free makes
more
money then you should
[Music]
know and the Beautiful song in a foreign
language that could be sing anything
[Music]
song Hello hello am my way
I hope you like that one cuz it turns
out it's really freaking hard to find a
toky lan translator Beauty and the Beast
the I'm too good for this place song
There Go the
baker I'm gluten
free everyone here is so lame oh my God
I can't even believe this stupid town he
cra
Belle good morning peasant where are you
off to the book shop I just finished the
most wonderful story but you probably
don't know how to read sweet Christ you
read no one cares shut
[Music]
up work but treats us like we're
jerks the psyching yourself up song I
guess he's rich and sometimes kind but
he looks like a woolly m is shaved
behind I do love dogs but I'm
not a dog is think I
could the it sucks to work here song go
ahead stuff your face we are both stuck
in this place we got here with no idea
we turn into an Ikea there's no breaks
there's no pay and we're trapped in here
all day just because my boss was a I
become a French Candlestick none of us
deserve it our poor friends he tet that
used to
[Music]
be I must confess we are oppressed get
snapped in half if we protest we so
stressed and depressed let us
rest and the toxic relationship song Cut
Her Off from
Friends
and a
family throw her in a cage fly into a
rage
unpredictably she can't get
[Music]
away she can't be released she's in
constant fair cuz she's trapped in there
please call the
police La La Land the Los Angeles song
City of
cars half your time spent here
driving stuck in your
car yelling tons of awful
things guys guys H I'm sorry no there
there's been aug huge mistake I
Moonlight you guys are this week's
honest trailer this is not a joke guys
Moonlight this is your honest trailer
but all we have left is another La La
Land song uh are we seriously going to
do this uh uhoh okay I think about that
night I got a Sandy handy from my friend
in the Moonlight Mersa Ali taught me to
swim and to be good help me grow up the
way I
should this ain't Boyhood and though I
grew up to D drugs my childhood friend
still gives me hugs my cultural identity
is a complex topic it's not easy being
black or gay or having a mom who's
on the true
story emotional
[Music]
complexity those are the
reasons Despicable Me one and two or
that forel song you liked at first until
it burrowed into your brain like a Molly
soak tape workm because it's clap if you
can't get this song out of your head
because it's clap if you wish was
something else
instead a clap if you sing this song
under your
breath clap along if you Sweet rele
Death stranger things Natasha
beningfield take
[Music]
one something strange is happening here
in Hawkin
to everything is
turning upside
down I will may be gone but our
friendship still strong so time the
sound up to 11 and right on
night strer
things I'm keeping our light
shining stranger
things these moments are def finding no
matter how hard we push and
cross uh Brian mcnight This Is Us
recording our lives cross manys and
times they're sad like losing a triplet
or you're adopted
dead what if your mom's lied to you your
entire life that's a lot of stri us
we're not cutting onions in here this is
us you'll be
buckets of
tears just except the end is near
[Music]
and hmates tail Poole you're
up waking up in my small B putting on
my life is good if you're a manale it's
just another hand t
I don't want to wait for the to take
over have just to give
birth I don't want to wait for the guys
to take over let the eyes see as we
smash the
[Music]
patriarchy
I love burn like
wildfire until you blew it
out now my watch is
ended the kingdoms are in
doubt winter is coming there's a wall
around my
heart I'm a wolfing dragon's clothing
and it's tearing me
apart I see it in the
flame get ready it from the
rain our love is not a game a game of
THS love is not a game
of
hold on hold on hold the hold
the so many names too many names in the
game of
thr shame on your game of
thr you know nothing
the greatest
showman the he wasn't a good guy
song ladies and gents I'm not a guy
that's we're cheering
for i h the slave I killed six
12 of fish
ta are true I don't look like you he was
an the madeup air
[Music]
song they will say we were in love but
we never were in
love never
love never in
love not me not me
not
me the these two people didn't even
exist song just made
up to make
the with stars Z is a and we're
super that's why they brought the to so
all of your cash would be
and the rampant cruelty
s that's not true that's
not Financial
G got now you to see that's look not oh
dear God what is that Eng for
fun
Mary poppin the recently unemployed song
oh crap I got sacked tonight cash will
be getting tight names don't laugh I
have to send you
packing the is sugar coat for something
song
reality is hard to take your mind can
need a break a spoon or three of liquid
teachy that's
cool working while sober makes you
mentally break down medicine around it's
kicking in right now just drink plenty
of water when you're feeling it come
down
quick it's almost
[Music]
420 the one is di van duck even saying s
Chim Chim Chim Chim Chim
chag
dues Chim Chim Chim Chim Chim Chim CH gr
tree sh off of dle till Brew the chimney
sweeps are actually exposed to lethal
amounts of carcinogen
song
and the 14 syll words are fun to say no
matter what they mean
[Music]
song A Star is Born Maybe maybe it's
time to let the remak
die maybe it's time to let the remakes
die for remakes is a lot to take held
this made my grandma
cry maybe it's time to let the remakes
die Lady
[Music]
Gag o la
[Applause]
la my
[Music]
M give
[Applause]
[Music]
Meer
my this a like that I'm by
[Music]
up now give us
[Applause]
roers mul
on the stereotypically Chinese song
those strings that isn't ancient Chinese
culture
cute voice cast too get most of
this the glorified chant masquerading as
a song song that the music what most
Disney fans find
charmings in
alarming you can leave the in the Life
focus on the but in the cartoon us
more the no time to explain but mul can
fight now song the second act is
starting
UL still
weak cue the training
montage and go take a
leak by the time you're through she'll
be a dude who can fight like rock
for that's what
sounds like this one are good
for and the Not So subtle coming out
song Get CED
gay
[Applause]
[Music]
you but when we look
G
get
[Music]
sorry
cworth
count every Quinton Tarantino
[Music]
movie all right feet
oh man look at them
[Music]
toes let's sniff some
shoes go feet
[Music]
go
enconto the magic powers that gloss over
serious issue
song she's got
a she's either or she'll drown you in
the might old
Bruno Bruno no they say he's got
depression and maybe
OC that's my mom Jula here's her deal
she uses food to Stu how you feel her
love get into meals if she's repressed
imagine how I feel mom what this family
needs is
therapy my whole family needs some
therapy I guess I'm lucky that all I
have is anxiety cuz this family needs
all the therapy oh crap the linman is
trying to tell us something
song to
uhoh resser after in the Heights was a
total
flop hoping that encounter gives him any
good win so we all forget his rolling
merry poins Overexposed but he can't
take a
break money's
great and the song that she'll not be
named Bliss don't start singing Bruno
God no no we can stop singing
Bruno help it was my
wedd started playing and I'm reading my
BS to the sky our heads till we die
begins in my head not again again it's
become the SRA of my life be cursed by
this s bur deep inside your brain
musical tapeworm you're going so insane
sing it while I'm pooping we're singing
it again dog's day there's no Escape
please don't stop singing brw no please
no no we can't stop singing
brw pocah
Hardis you think my tribe are Ordinary
People and claim a land you think you
can
explain but we are all imbued with
superpowers we know magic we are druid
WDS I'm a
mage I'm basically an X-Man or
Avenger the Heron and the order I
command and if you cross me John you
will
discover I can War into this bird that's
on my hand and they'll never hear your
voice cry will the end come soon when I
dish out the payback for your
skins I could blow you from this Lion
King as
Mountain I control the ancient forces of
the
wind if you cross me then I will grind
your bones to dust
until you're just
pieces I can
scatter
in
the
way
[Music]
Elvis and all the crot shards well
that's my dick mama that's my dick too
that's my dick mama let way do that's my
dick that's my dick that's my dick my
know any way you
do I said d d d d a d
d Lord have
mercy
[Music]
Velma the dogs where to be found Scooby
dodoo where are
youma had and put down you know that HBO
is cutting shows with somma Dodge the
ass don't come back in this cartoon the
point of view is mean and shill and all
the jokes are hack that's a
fact carto networks through slashed into
they canell all theong shows
scob this
is the dogs
balls The
Goonies Coastal count he Queen Ag Oregon
Coastal count twen AG Oregon Coastal
count he's got to save their
[Applause]
home
[Music]
W now
Mike
Mach me wild of kinds of fooden
Oren or
coal Coal searching for some
sh are you high as a kite did you hit up
the bar is your mind prepped to see M
bizar are you ready to G like an open
mou B your lucky star you can't see up
their ass are the J cats what the hell
is a
cat
jel cats fire yourent cats eal
cats
cats cats magn cats all regrettable cats
all these cats will you at night break
to God to
Rob and see all your Broadway friends
having fun
[Music]
[Applause]
we
sing that's how the plot goes in fact
it's more stupid than
that learn the dumb names of the8 or9
mains Mr M Jenny any dos skimble Shanks
ravity bu Jones Mango Jerry trumple
teaser aspar go old
Deuteronomy then J gets in a
[Music]
balloon laugh while youing as your mind
unhinged while you to make sense
out
ineffable get ready for a horror show
that will sh take you to your core full
of images to haunt your dreams as your
jaw drops to the floor like these
roaches with a human face or Wilson's
Tain the body horror on display makes
Cronenberg look
[Music]
qut a Travy a try this movie is the have
SE The Cinematic hairball packed with
shocking
abnormality how big are cat supp to be
no don't care now close your eyes and go
to sleep Dame Judy's face will be
there nobody saw this phenomenal bomb
that lost tons of money reviews were all
C
and we all sing Oh Hell never was there
ever a failed Endeavor this tragic oh
God won't you stop it please this tragic
oh wow never have I ever had to get
Hammer to finish a mov now
[Music]
stop
forever I want to my please
J
[Music]
[Applause]
story me or
Dr
me to get rid of
[Music]
the cat has
just
this
will me
to understand what craing this
is but to
[Music]
ro is
so balls of
furry